the time has come when we turn tables on
the costume designers they're the ones
sitting on pins and needles to present
the needle worker's Awards a beautiful
young star who was once a fashion model
and a rugged leading man with a style
all his own Candis Bergen and Robert
Mitchum
candy I can understand why you were
picked to present the costume design
awards but why a Mitchum oh he knows all
about fashion bum
haven't you seen no smart me his wife
dresses really you pick her clothes that
was a matter of fact she makes her own I
just tend the patterns in the materials
I used to do that for Dolores until like
that dress makers need candy would you
begin please for the best achievement in
black and white costume design the
nominees are Danny no Donati for the
Gospel according to st. Matthew the name
of the naughty for a mandragora Helen
Rose for mr. bud wing
Justin regard for Morgan Irene sheriff
for Who's Afraid of Virginia Woolf and
now for the women the winner is
Irene Who's Afraid of Virginia Mary
accepting the award on behalf of Irene
Sherrod an evil to leave
it is with great pride and great honor
that I accept on behalf of Miss Irene
sheriff this marvelous award I hope that
I have attempted to say what I know that
she would have said under the
circumstances
the best achievement in costume design
of a color picture are the nominees are
rather generally for a gambit
Dorothy chickens from Hawaii Carol
Girardi for Julian of the spirits in
this event - and Joan range for a man of
all seasons Edith Head for the Oscar
would you read the women please can the
winners are Elizabeth happened in and
Joan bridge for a man for all seasons
accepting the award for Elizabeth
happened inand Joan bridge for a man for
all seasons
Helen rolls
on behalf of my two very talented
colleagues from Britain Elizabeth
Hoffman and John bridge I'm very proud
and privileged to accept this award for
them thank you very much